[Musique]
écoute bien c un tango quand j'étais ch
on le dansait corp contre corps on s tra
pour tout temps que ça durit écoute bien
c'est un tango dansse reine de mes
printemps dans fleur de mes 17 ans le
T écoute bien ne souris pas à benoire
pzola te ferait comendre
ilicer contrario écoute bien
rapproche-toi le vent nous porte loin
déjà guériign pas lestic de mon
tango
dans tango de la première
chance Tang des rire et des
silence on danse les yeux dans les
yeux
dans T des dernières
vacan Tang de la vie qui
balance découverte du
merveilleux trois musicien bass et piano
soutenant le Bandon néon nous faisait
gravir colquun tous les étages de la
passion écoute un peu si c'est bidon ça
viit ça bouge le tango ce n'est pas la
danse en solo mais enend duo et ne rit
pas c'est pas malin ça vaut bien les
rythmes ricains où chacun danse dans son
coin où chacun dansse en VAG c'est pas
la danse incognito mais c'est le feu le
bras zéro non ne crie pas si vite à sur
le
monango
dans tango dans la première
chance tango des rires et des
silence on danse les yeux dans les
yeux
dan Tang des dernières
vacances de la vie
quience découverte du
merveilleux écoute bien cet un quand
j'étais jeune on le dansa contre cor C
RGÉ pour tout le temps que ça durait
écoute bien c'est uno dans ce rve de mes
printemps dans fleur de mes 17 c'est le
T écoute bien ne souris pas àos cela te
ferait comprendre Ilic t'imposer
contrario écoute bien rapproche-toi le
vent nous porte loin déjà grgote pas
l'érotico de mon
[Musique]
tango téléspectateurs vous connaissez
toutes